Speaker 1: One of the best things that could
happen for the left is for the right to do
damage to itself by just getting involved
in complete and total nonsense. When I hear
complete and total nonsense, one of the first
names that comes to mind is Mike Lindell Pillow,
the CEO and founder of Mypillow, who has been a
guest on this program multiple times. Don't miss
my last interview with him. It was pretty wacked.
Mike Pillow is officially launching his campaign
for Republican Party chairman. He is targeting
Ronna McDaniel. He says Ronna McDaniel is leading
the party in the wrong direction. And part of his
evidence of that is that the election from a few
weeks ago should have been a massive red wave.
And it wasn't. And here is Mike Pillow making
it clear he's really doing this. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: It should have been the biggest red
wave in the history of the world, right? Ever. It
should be the biggest red wave in the
history of the United States. And, you know,
and it didn't happen. And why didn't it happen?
Well, the donors want to know. We put in
all the money. Come on. What happened? Well,
you better find out what happened. The the RNC
completely lied to the American people and to
their donors and said that they would go after
election integrity. They called it integrity.
I call it election crime. Oh, yeah. We're all
for election integrity. Really? What have you
done? What did you do in 2020? You know what you
did in 2020? What the RNC did, everybody is they
all got together and here's a fact and said, oh,
we're not going to do anything because we could
get sued. That would be one of their excuses.
We could get sued by the machine companies.
Well, let's just let our country be destroyed
and let's just keep taking money from our donors.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine if this guy was
the chairman of the Republican National
Committee? Oh, my goodness.
Speaker 3: And we hope that
we can override the algorithms.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we should. We
should encourage this. We should support this
wholeheartedly. Even if pillow doesn't win,
it would be a very nice distraction for the
Republican Party. So maybe they don't do as
many damaging things. And just on the off chance
that pillow wins, it would wreak total havoc on
the 2024 primary. It would bring in a massively
pro-Trump RNC chair, which is the exact opposite.
Of what the establishment Republican Party wants
to see at this point in time, the left should 100%
be supporting this. And no, I still haven't gotten
those free pillows from Mike Pillow at this point.
I don't even really know that I want them. So to
take kind of a more 30,000 foot view of the RNC
and the Republican Party thinking about 2020 for
what the Republican Party. Absent even the pillow
stuff is going to have to figure out for 2024
is do they go fully against Trump? But if they
do that, the risk is Trump wins the nomination
and then what happens? Or do they just remain
sort of neutral publicly behind the scenes, try to
work against Trump so that if indeed Trump is the
2024 Republican nominee, there's still some sort
of plausible deniability or ability to work with
Trump and to try to get him to do some things that
they would like to see him do. I, quite frankly,
can't imagine what a 2024 Trump presidency would
be starting in 2025 if Donald Trump were to win
because he seems completely uninterested in actual
governance. There's not even a pretense of policy
other than these vague things. What we're going to
shut down the border crossings again, even though
nothing really changed since he left and Biden,
it's not really policy. He's not even pretending
that he's going to get us that beautiful health
care plan any more. So I don't know what such a
presidency looks like. And the RNC would probably
be well advised if they think there's any shot
that Trump has at this thing, which clearly
Trump has some shot. How do they stay enough
in his good graces that they can actually get
him to achieve some policy things or even pay
attention to them? That's the real question.
I don't know which direction they'll go in